you know I want to congratulate you you
are the youngest ever in celebrity
history to play in the celebrity
all-star game right yes and it's true I
mean all the cool celebrities play in
this game and this was kind of a dream
of yours right pretty much yes I've
always wanted to be in the NBA and the
NBA celebrity all-star games like
probably the biggest celebrity gave me
to be played and I've always wanted to
play and I've been on the roster fried
say like three years in a row now it's
just like me being on blackish I've
never had the chance to like they've
never made me available to actually fly
there and right well beyond beador so
you were on the roster for a long time
and then finally you got to play yes and
one of your assignments was to guard a
gentleman named Justin Bieber is that
correct yeah you let the guard Justin
Bieber and I am impressed because look
at this Bieber is going up for two and
you are really going for it you were
really trying to take him down pressure
for you miles did he make that shot no
he did not
it's just the craziest thing about that
picture is that it's so like it's such
much of a coincidence that I got to meet
him the first time I actually got to
meet him was 2011 and the NBA all-star
game was here in LA yeah and and and I
was I'd say five or six years old at the
time and he was the youngest to ever
play in the game cuz he was only like
like 16 or like 17 yeah he used to be
the youngest you broke that record yeah
and you know I broke that record yeah
it's just crazy that I got to meet them
meet him at the same spot and I got to
play against him and I and I got to
prove to him that I got so you know
blockers or not block what can really
drop his shot anymore hit me the abdomen
but that's okay
I contested it in the eyes yeah yeah you
threw chalk up in the air yeah
you